hey guys justin and mike here we're at
the nintendo in these event at PAX 2015
they're calling this Mindy's at night
too clever puns the mountain Weber we
get it it's on the wall back here
somewhere a lot of really cool games not
a lot of new stuff but a little bit of
new stuff we one of the new things that
we did see was shovel Knight but yeah
laying expansion we've known that
somebody's gonna have an expansion for a
while this is the first time we've
gotten to play it and it's very
difficult controlling this new character
it's a lot of fun i really enjoyed
learning how this new character works
even if i was really terrible at it but
I mean that's what I love about trouble
night it still has that great that's the
great art the great music plays and
captures then 8-bit 16-bit still
difficult still still brutally difficult
but I feel like I'll get used to it
thank you you played a little bit of
Pancho yeah I played Pancho it's sort of
remind me of Fez especially the art
style it's kind of that boxy really
pixelated you know cartoon look almost
maybe not cartoon but definitely very
very much like a buzz was in terms of
perspective and everything um but you
can ship to the foreground you can ship
to the background there's a few parts
where the moving platforms you really
had to make sure that you were you know
just getting it to the right spot and
the right plane you know like flame
shipping up the platform yourself look
pretty simple but then when they throw
in like certain certain planes would
line up differently and their behold in
certain spots where you can ship forward
and then hit that and then walk a little
bit shift back so it was pretty
straightforward at first but then you
know there are few like twist
gameplay throne that perspective and
poncho kind of illustrates one of the
things that Nintendo is doing in a
really interesting way the poncho is
already out and it's been out on pc it's
again you could already plate and that's
just a lot of games here tonight and I
think that's really interesting that
Nintendo isn't shutting down I mean you
think of one we use a third party in the
way that that's working there's not a
lot of support there's not a lot of EA
or Activision games but on the indie
side like this is kind of huge that
we're also getting kerbal space program
action Hank like all these games that
have been out there but the fear that
they're both supporting the wii u and
that nintendo is actively looking for
that support and i think it's always
great you know to have a place where
these creative teams and might not have
the resources of triple-a developers
which those games are always awesome too
but you know it's great to see these
small ideas become something bigger when
they have the resources to do that with
and that's one of the most exciting
things to see it taxes both the
community that's round all these games
also all these any developers and the
exciting games they have and will be
checking out more from their attacks
2015 stay tuned to gamespot stock
you